as the saying goes it's not the size
that counts it's how you use it but does
this long-standing phrase ring true in
the hugely debated topic of penis size
does your member actually make a
difference in attractiveness or ability
to pleasure your partner interestingly
humans have the largest penis of any
primate both an absolute size and
relative to body proportions so you can
be proud of that through our
evolutionary history
females likely developed an interest and
preference for penis shape and size much
like how female peacocks have a
preference for a male with stunning
feathers as a result they chose mates
with larger penises ultimately passing
on those genes this is known as sexual
selection it may also have been an
advantage for males as a longer penis is
more efficient at removing the sperm of
rival males during intercourse the
longer your depth of thrust the better
semen displacement ensuring your genes
get passed on one particular study found
that some women experienced more
frequent vaginal orgasms with longer
penises suggesting that it may be able
to stimulate the entire length of the
vagina and the cervix however it's
important to note that women experience
different types of orgasms in fact
vaginal and clitoral orgasms may be
completely separate phenomenon they use
different nerves and even stimulate
different areas of the brain even the
coveted g-spot another sexually
sensitive area and women is located only
one third of the way into the vagina
apart from this many surveys of women
have found that they're not nearly as
concerned with size as men might think
and preferences vary however studies on
homosexual men have shown that they
regard a larger penis as ideal another
study in 2013 actually found that
flaccid penis size may also be a major
factor in male attractiveness even
before sexual contact which may seem odd
considering we wear clothes nowadays but
for our ancestors the genitals would
have been visible in the study women
were asked to rank the attractiveness of
males based on computer generated images
reflecting different body types and
penis sizes from this it was clear that
not only were taller and more fit men
much more desirable but flaccid penis
size played a role in their perceived
attractiveness to the larger the penis
the higher they were rated but there was
a limit a flaccid penis larger than
about seven point six centimeters and
attractiveness began to diminish
it would seem a penis in proportion may
be most desirable after all over
exaggerated traits even those related to
attractiveness can often be a sign of
problems and it turns out that the
person attached to the penis makes a
difference too with most all studies
showing confidence enjoyable personality
and attraction being the best predictor
of sexual satisfaction ultimately while
science does seem to matter in some ways
bigger isn't always better just be glad
you don't have a bean weevils penis we
break down some of the craziest genitals
Nature has to offer in our new ASAP
thought video seriously there is some
crazy stuff out there so be sure to
check the video out click the screen or
use the link in the description and
subscribe for more weekly science videos